بدلت الارض غير الارض فبعد ما يقارب 120
يوما من العدوان استحالت المدينه العصاميه
ركاما يتفرج عليه العاجزون
والشامتون لكنه ركام يبني وعيا ويقدم
دروسا حسب كثيرين بل ويشحذ عزائم اجيال
لما تولد
[موسيقى]
بعد ثم هو ركام ما يفت شرره يتطاير عالميا
وان الظهير الدولي للاحتلال محاصرته مع من
يحاصر في حارات غزه فقد تطاير شرره الى
خمس دول عربيه فجبت لبنان مشتعله
والامريكيون مهددون في قواعدهم بين الاردن
وسوريا والعراق والسفن ذات الصله بدوله
الاحتلال ترتعد في البحر حيث يكمل لها
اليمنيون المفعل بالام
غزه شراره العدوان وصلت كذلك الى احرار
العالم فاستيقظوا تقودهم جنوب افريقيا
المسكونه بصراع الطويل مع المحتل الاتي من
وراء البحار متذكره اهاتها الشبيهه باهات
فلسطين فوقف المحتل للمره الاولى بهذا
الزخم مدانا تحاصره عباءه القضاه وهو الذي
مرد على الحمايه الدائمه وعلى التحا في
ثوب
الضحيه شراره العدوان وصلت كذلك الى عالم
الافكار والتصورات فاستيقظ الناس على زيف
السرديات المتحذلق حول حقوق الانسان
والمساواه بين الاديان والاعراق حيث قام
الطوفان وما تلاه بكنس كل ذلك باعتباره
خدعه من خدع
الماضي وهكذا اصبح كثير من الشباب
المتظاهر ما بين واشنطن وجاكرتا مقتنعا ان
تلك المحكيات انما صنعت لتخدير المغلوب لا
لنصرته في لحظات الضيق
ومخانيث
كذلك على الداخل الاسرائيلي وعلى رؤيه
المحتلين لدولتهم ومشروعهم الاستيطاني
فالخلافات تتسع بين قاده مجلس الحرب بعد
فشلهم في تحقيق الاهداف المعلنه
للعدوان فلا حماس خرجت من التاريخ ولا
الفلسطينيون رفعوا الرايه البيضاء ولا
اسرى السابع من اكتوبر عادوا الى ذويهم
مكرمين كل ذلك يجعل اسرائيل اكثر انكشافا
من ذي قبل واكثر اضطرارا للتنكر في ثوب
الضحيه كما تفعل الان ويفعل المحتلون
دووما